Okay, so what we have seen just now is that basically even the ideal process
that can execute any number of instructions per cycle. Still has obey raw
dependencies. Meaning, it still has to wait for results to be produced before
they can be used by instructions that need those results. And that really
creates some of the delays that the ideal processor is going to have. And
that's why the ILP is not 0, it's going to be something larger than 0 even for
an ideal processor. So let us now look at some instructions. So
let's say that I1 is producing the value that's being used by I2.
Then I3 is producing the value for I4. And then, I4 produces the value that is
used for I5. So what is going to be the CPI for this particular program.
Well it's going to be CPI is equal, how many cycles do we need for
this, for these five instructions? Well here's what's going to happen.
I1 can execute immediately in the first cycle. And so, can I3 because it
doesn't have to wait for anything. So we spend one cycle executing I1 and I3.
The next cycle I2 can now go. And I4 can also go because I3 is now done.
And then, we still need a third cycle to execute I5 which has to wait for I4.
So we have spent three cycles for five instructions,
which is going to be a CPI of 0.6. So the CPI is still lower than one.
But now it's even larger. And finally,
if we did have this dependence as well. Now we have to do I1 and then I2, and
then I3, and then I4, and then I5. So then now the CPI with this is going
to be one. Why? Well because we need five cycles to execute five instructions so
the CPA's going to be one. So basically in the program the dependencies, the,
the raw dependencies are going to determine basically what is the possible CPI.
Even if the processor can do everything else ideally. Meaning it can fetch
a number of instructions, it can decode and read registers in any number of,
instructions. But it simply cannot provide time travel, which is,
which is kind of the only consideration that you really consider in this case.
Is just that we cannot do time travel. Everything else we can do.
We still have a CPI that is somewhere between one and 0. You will
have a CPI of 0 if a very large number with no dependencies. We have seen that.
We have a CPI of one. If you have any number of instructions that are all
dependant on the previous instructions, you really can not let anything get by